deux côtés volontairement ce soir le
côté artistique pour nous intéresser aux
retombées économiques de ce festival
reportage domique hangar philippe rix
chaque année le festival de pau mobilise
une dizaine de milliers de spectateurs
un nombre régulièrement en progression
de 5 à 10%
mais avec un directeur aussi connu et
influent que les roger hanin et une
qualité de spectacle que nul ne conteste
le festival at-il en ce tout début d'été
une incidence véritable sur l'économie
paloise
l'impact économique qu'il apporte si
j'en crois à une certaine enquête que
nous avions fait professionnellement
c'est la dernière des manifestations
pour l'impact économique que l'on puisse
enregistrer tant sur le plan de l'impact
direct que l'impact n 10 l'hôtellerie à
pau et dans ses environs offrent mille
600 chambres toutes catégories
confondues or tous les hôteliers sont
unanimes le festival bloc 15 à 20
chambres pour les artistes
une centaine quand un orchestre est
présent à part ça rien le festival ne
semble tourner qu'avec son seul public
palois ont joué à guichet fermé pour les
grandes créations comme les fourberies
de scapin cette année ou pour guy bedos
et les places s'arrachent dès leur mise
en vente
en revanche les spectacles locaux
régionaux connaissent eux une baisse
sensible d'affluence alors que peut-on
faire
et peut-on faire quelque chose pour
mobiliser le public extérieur
les idées ne manquent pas faudrait
peut-être besoin pour son festival de de
prendre un créneau de xiu prévu
l'envergure au point de vue publicité au
point de vue motivation pour attirer les
gens de l'extérieur delà des régions
environnantes pour les responsables de
l'office de tourisme ce calcul
économique au coup par coup n'est pas
valable
il ne faut pas distille isoler le
festival d'un ensemble de manifestations
culturelles qui veulent redonner une vie
touristique au centre urbain et l'on
pense immédiatement au grand prix avec
ses dizaines de milliers de spectateurs
est une ville de pau connu dans le monde
entier
alors bien sûr les commerçants
aimeraient bien que ce soit le grand
prix toute l'année